have a look through this data and find
out exactly what we're talking about
here but we're talking about data from
Freedom of Information requests requests
from every police force for the last
three years and they were asked about
crimes where they'd been some
involvement of Twitter and Facebook and
really some of these more used to
hearing about cyberbullying now but some
of the other threats are quite serious
indeed threats to kill harassment sexual
offences I mean what should we read into
this because of course not all these
cases we should say actually mean that a
threat to kill was made over Twitter
there was just some mention of Twitter
in it no absolutely right so the crimes
which are conducted on social media are
very broad and diverse some are
relatively unserious others incredibly
serious indeed a small body of them have
very serious offline consequences indeed
we've seen people being financially
ruined due to things happening on social
media in a small number of cases we've
actually seen people committing suicide
too so really quite serious cases let
you say a whole range of cases there so
let's take a closer look at exactly what
they are forces actually reported not
all of those approached at reported
figures but 24 out of 45 forces said
there'd been some rise in the figures
where Twitter had been involved even
when it comes to Facebook 38 out of 45
saying that actual fact they'd seen an
increase when it came to the number of
cases where Facebook was being cited as
well so it's a significant not every
force as saying they've seen an increase
no indeed and surprising that it isn't
every year we're seeing millions more
people beginning to use social media
using it regularly yes now we spend more
internet minutes using social media than
any other formula tivity online over
half of us regularly social media in
Britain and every week so so I'm
surprised that not all forces where
you've seen this this is a story of us
trying to deal with both the bad as well
as a good side of kind of living in the
digital age but it is quite significant
when you look please break this down to
some of the areas in particular to take
a look first of all at london and the
Metropolitan Police you can see there
the number of cases there involving
Facebook they say has risen from 135 in
2012 to over 1,200 last year she chopped
arise if we look at what happened in
Greater Manchester bear the number
cases that cited Facebook being involved
somewhere doubling since 2012 959 last
year and if you look at staffordshire
that was the biggest actually you can
see there over 1200 and a 69 if you
saying there no part of this is do with
our greater use of social media but
what's quite clear as well it's not just
a case at the number of cases arising
enforcement isn't always working either
is it no you can see from this graph
here really gives you a sense of how
quickly this phenomenon is emerging so
so the police really are i think
scrambling to catch up with having to
consistently apply laws now online as
well as offline you know they're faced
with the numbers different challenges
around investigations around and of
course how to do this in a way which is
consistent with people's privacy's and
enlisting with their sense of freedom of
course and we look at staff at your
figures in more details quite
interesting you break it down because
they say 326 cases in both some form of
harassment 38 threats to kill 13 rape
allegations involving minors are really
quite a tall task here at what is the
solution where do we go from here so it
sounds like science fiction but I really
do think we have to move towards a cyber
police force a special specialist group
of police officers who are trained and
equipped with the technology and the
skills they need to actually go about
and investigate crimes that either just
based on line or have an important
digital dimension to them thank